À chaque seconde qui passe, il y a quelque part dans le monde un avion qui décolle
et ailleurs un autre qui atterrit
et quelle que soit l'heure à laquelle vous me regardiez
il y en a probablement pas loin de 15 000 qui sont en train de voler dans les airs
Et pourtant à en croire certains
on n'aurait pas encore réellement compris
comment les avions volent
Genre, vraiment ?
c'est pas très rassurant non ?
Il faut dire que si on essaye de se renseigner sur le sujet
il semblerait qu'il y ait plusieurs théories concurrentes pour expliquer le vol des avions
Et il y a même des débats assez violents entre les défenseurs de l'une ou de l'autre
qui se prennent le bec sur des forums d'initiés
Alors aujourd'hui on va regarder ensemble cette question
et je vous rassure tout de suite, on comprend très bien comment les avions volent
Pour commencer, expliquons en quoi le fait qu'un avion vole est a priori plutôt étonnant
et pour ça on peut faire la comparaison avec une fusée
Quand une fusée décolle, elle est soumise
à son poids du fait de la gravité
et d'un autre côté ses moteurs
lui fournisse une force qu'on appelle la poussée
qui vient s'opposer à ce poids ce qui lui permet de s'élever
et si on veut être complet on peut rajouter que dans l'atmosphère on a aussi des frottement de l'air
qui s'opposent au mouvement
et forment ce qu'on appelle la traînée
Maintenant un avion c'est assez différent
il est aussi soumis à son poids, qui est évidemment vertical
mais cette fois les moteurs
fournissent une poussée horizontale
alors ça permet à l'avion d'avancer,  c'est très bien
il subit d'ailleurs lui aussi une trainée
mais vous voyez que ça ne vient pas compenser le poids
Alors comment l'avion fait-il pour tenir en l'air ?
Eh bien il subit en fait une force supplémentaire, qu'on appelle la portance
qui est dirigée verticalement vers le haut, et permet de compenser le poids
de sorte qu'en régime de croisière, l'avion reste à une altitude constante
Et la question c'est donc : d'où vient cette force de portance ?
et bien pour comprendre son origine, il va falloir s'intéresser à l'air dans lequel baigne l'avion
et qui va jouer un rôle essentiel
C'est la différence majeure
avec une fusée :
sur un astre sans atmosphère, on peut très bien faire décoller une fusée
ce qui est quand même pratique pour revenir de la lune par exemple
par contre un avion ça ne marcherait pas : un avion a besoin de l'air pour voler
Une manière de poser le problème, c'est d'imaginer l'air immobile et l'avion qui se déplace dedans horizontalement
à une certaine vitesse grâce à la poussée de ses moteurs
Mais une autre façon équivalente de le voir, c'est de se placer du point de vue de l'avion, dans son référentiel
Et cette fois, c'est plutôt l'avion qui est immobile et l'air qui lui arrive dessus, comme du vent si vous voulez
on parle parfois de vent relatif
et d'ailleurs cette image du vent arrivant sur l'avion
me permet de souligner que tout ce qu'on va discuter aujourd'hui
s'applique de façon analogue au voilier
une voile et une aile d'avion, c'est essentiellement la même chose
Et pour les deux la question est la même : comment le vent relatif peut créer une force ?
et dans le cas de l'avion, la portance qui le maintient en l'air ?
Et bien essayons d'y répondre
Une première hypothèse très simple, ce serait d'imaginer que l'avion se maintient grâce à
l'impact de ce vent qui vient frapper la face inférieure des ailes
comme les ailes ont toujours une petite inclinaison, qu'on appelle l'angle d'attaque
c'est assez logique d'imaginer que l'avion, en quelque sorte, prend appui sur l'air pour se maintenir comme avec un ricochet
cette hypothèse a l'avantage d'être simple, et on peut facilement calculer la portance qu'on obtient
en fonction de la vitesse, de la densité de l'air, et de l'angle d'attaque
Mais malheureusement, si on fait ce calcul, on trouve des valeurs de portance bien trop faibles pour expliquer pourquoi les avions volent
et en plus il y a certaines situations pour lesquelles cette explication ne fonctionne manifestement pas
notamment par exemple pour des voiliers qui "remontent au vent", c'est à dire se déplacent entre 45 et 90 degrés face au vent
Et bien avec cette simple théorie de l'impact de l'air ça ne devrait pas être possible
les voiliers devraient même reculer, et pourtant ils avancent
Malgré tout, l'idée à un fond de vérité :
on sait que l'air est un gaz composé de molécules, et donc oui, ces molécules entrent en collision avec les ailes des avions
mais pas de cette façon là
Le point important, c'est que dans un gaz, les molécules sont en permanence en déplacement très rapide
À température ambiante, les molécules qui composent l'air ont une vitesse d'environ 350 mètres par seconde
plus de 1000 kilomètres/heure
et elles entrent en collision les unes avec les autres à un rythme effréné
chaque molécule subi plusieurs milliards de collisions par seconde
et donc même en l'absence complète de vent, les molécules de l'air autour de nous sont extrêmement agitées
mais l'air n'a pas de mouvement global car toutes les vitesses se compensent
Maintenant si vous avez du vent à, disons, 50 km/heure
eh bien ça ne fait que rajouter un léger mouvement global uniforme à ce chaos de molécules qui s'entrechoquent en permanence
Alors pourquoi c'est important de parler de cette agitation microscopique des molécules ?
Eh bien parce qu'évidemment, elles viennent à tout moment frapper tous les objets, vous y compris
et bien entendu les ailes des avions
Quand un avion est au sol, à l'arrêt sur la piste
il subit une quantité astronomique de collisions de la part des molécules de l'air, notamment sur ses ailes
mais tout se compense : les chocs sur la face inférieure sont équilibrés par ceux de la face supérieure
En revanche, quand il est en mouvement à une certaine vitesse
ces collisions existent toujours des deux côtés
mais il va y avoir légèrement plus de collisions sur la face inférieure des ailes
et légèrement moins sur la face supérieure
et c'est cette différence qui va créer la portance qui permet aux avions de se maintenir dans les airs
Alors évidemment, il nous reste à comprendre pourquoi il y aurait plus de collisions d'un côté que de l'autre
mais d'un point de vue fondamental, au niveau microscopique, il n'y a aucun mystère dans la portance
c'est une affaire de différentiel de collisions des molécules de l'air sur la surface des ailes
Alors creusons un peu
Pour comprendre ce qui se passe, on peut prendre le profil d'une aile
c'est à dire une vue en deux dimensions, en coupe, ça ressemble souvent à ça
et essayer de visualiser la manière dont l'air s'écoule autour quand l'avion avance
Alors je vous rappelle qu'on se met du point de vue de l'avion
donc on imagine l'aile immobile et l'air qui lui arrive dessus à une certaine vitesse
pour visualiser l'écoulement de l'air, on a deux solutions
D'un côté on peut faire des expériences en soufflerie :
on place l'aile dans un tunnel avec un flux d'air
et en injectant de la fumée à certains endroits dans le flux en amont de l'aile
on peut visualiser sa trajectoire
Vous voyez sur cette vidéo les lignes formées par la fumée
évidemment entre ces lignes il y a aussi un écoulement
c'est juste qu'on le voit pas parce qu'on n'a pas injecté de la fumée partout
L'autre solution pour visualiser ces flux, c'est de faire une simulation avec un ordinateur
il se trouve que les équations qui régissent la mécanique d'un fluide comme l'air sont bien connues
on les appelle les équations de Navier-Stokes
et elles nous permettent de simuler un écoulement autour d'une aile de forme donnée
c'est ce que j'ai fait par exemple ici : vous voyez le profil de l'aile, elle a un certain angle d'attaque
et les lignes qui sont tracées représentent les flux d'air, et montrent la façon dont ils vont contourner l'aile
on retrouve évidemment le même type de motif qu'en soufflerie
il faut donc imaginer que si on lâchait un petit objet léger dans l'écoulement, disons une poussière
et bien il suivrait la trajectoire de la ligne de flux sur laquelle il se trouve
Cette représentation nous permet de voir comment les flux d'air se déplacent
Mais en fait, il n'y a pas que ça
vous savez peut-être que l'air a une certaine masse volumique, une densité
on ne le réalise pas au quotidien, mais un mètre cube d'air pèse un peu plus d'un kilogramme
sauf que cette densité peut varier :
elle dépend de la quantité de molécules présentes à un endroit donné, qui elle-même dépend des flux d'air
Et justement, les équations qu'on utilise pour la simulation nous donnent aussi la densité de l'air qui s'écoule
et la voici représentée ici autour de notre aile
en blanc ce sont les zones où la densité est normale
en rouge les zones où l'air est plus comprimé, où la densité est plus élevée
et en bleu c'est l'inverse, la densité est plus faible
et ces variations de densité sont importantes, parce qu'elles influencent directement
la quantité de chocs que les molécules de l'air font subir à la surface de l'aile
Dans cette configuration, à cause des variations de densité, c'est à dire de la quantité de molécules présentes
la face supérieure de l'aile va subir moins de chocs de la part de ces molécules
et la face inférieure en subira plus
Et c'est cette différence qui crée la portance
Cette variation de la densité de l'air autour des ailes, et donc de la quantité de chocs moléculaires
on peut l'exprimer comme une variation de pression :
l'air sous l'aile est en légère surpression, et l'air au-dessus en légère dépression
et c'est ce différentiel de pression qui permet de calculer la portance
Une illustration frappante de ces phénomènes, c'est qu'on voit parfois des sortes de nuages se former au dessus des ailes des avions
et il s'agit en fait de condensation de gouttelettes d'eau provoquée par la chute de pression sur la face supérieure
Pour essayer de comprendre un peu plus d'où viennent ces différences de pression qui créent la portance
on peut retourner à notre simulation des flux d'air
une chose que je n'ai pas encore montrée sur le graphique des lignes de flux
c'est que la vitesse de l'air varie aux différents endroits
regardez : si je lâche une poussière ici, elle avance à une certaine vitesse
et puis elle subit une accélération, se déplace plus vite
avant de ralentir à nouveau
Sur le schéma, on peut s'amuser à indiquer avec un code couleur la vitesse sur les lignes de flux
rouge correspond aux vitesses les plus élevées, et bleu aux vitesses les plus faibles
et vous voyez qu'au voisinage de l'aile, on a des sacrées différences
Vous remarquez d'ailleurs peut-être quelque chose :
les zones de vitesse élevée correspondent exactement aux zones de faible pression qu'on a vues tout à l'heure
et les zones de vitesse plus faible, aux zones de haute pression
Regardez, je vous mets la comparaison
Ce lien qu'on observe entre vitesse de l'air et pression, il n'est pas dû au hasard
c'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le principe de Bernoulli :
le long d'une ligne de flux d'air, il y a une relation, qu'on peut démontrer, et qui lie nécessairement la pression et la vitesse
de sorte que quand la vitesse augmente la pression diminue et inversement
On peut donc dire que d'une certaine façon c'est grâce au principe de Bernoulli que la portance existe
et que les avions peuvent voler
Alors il faut l'avouer, ce principe de Bernoulli n'est pas hyper simple à appréhender
associer une augmentation de la vitesse à une baisse de pression peut paraître un peu contre-intuitif
et en plus, ce principe il faut faire un peu attention à comment on l'applique
on a envie de penser que de façon générale, vitesse=dépression
mais c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça, parce que ça s'applique le long d'une ligne de flux
Petite parenthèse d'ailleurs
une conséquence de ça, c'est qu'on illustre parfois le principe de Bernoulli de cette façon
en soufflant sur le dessus d'une feuille
et en montrant qu'elle se redresse
mais ça n'est pas exactement une bonne application du principe de Bernoulli
et c'est pas ce qui se passe avec un avion, où l'air se déplace des deux côtés
et c'est important pour avoir le droit de comparer les pressions
Bref, donc c'est Bernoulli qui fait voler des avions, très bien
Sauf que pour une raison qu'on verra tout à l'heure
certaines personnes ne sont pas d'accord avec cette explication
et une autre théorie, supposément plus correcte, a été proposée
basée sur les principes énoncés par Newton
Alors voyons donc cette autre explication du vol des avions
qui n'est pas due à Newton lui-même mais qui est une conséquence de ses principes
Quand on observe les flux d'air autour d'une aile, vu d'assez loin, on peut noter une chose :
l'air arrive initialement avec une vitesse parallèle au sol
mais après avoir passé l'aile, il ressort avec une vitesse légèrement dirigée vers le bas
à la fois du fait que par en dessous il doit contourner l'aile
et par au-dessus il est dévié en épousant le profil de l'aile
Pour provoquer ce changement de vitesse, la deuxième loi de Newton nous dit que l'air a nécessairement subi une force
force qui a été exercée sur lui… par l'aile, vu qu'il y a rien d'autre
Oui, sauf que Newton nous a aussi légué un autre principe : celui de l'action-réaction
qu'on appelle parfois la troisième loi de Newton
Ce principe nous dit que si l'aile exerce une force sur l'air, eh bien l'air exercera une force opposée sur l'aile
force dirigée vers le haut, donc
et cette force, eh bien, c'est la portance qu'on cherche
et finalement ce serait donc Newton plutôt que Bernoulli qui ferait voler les avions
Cette explication à la Newton, elle est absolument incontestable, c'est de la physique de base
pas besoin de parler de pression comme avec Bernoulli
et donc certains la considèrent comme meilleure, plus correcte que celle basée sur le principe de Bernoulli
Et c'est assez amusant de voir des gens débattre pour défendre l'une ou l'autre
de façon parfois assez véhémente, voire violente
bah oui, on est sur internet
Mais ce qui est drôle, c'est que ces deux explications sont en fait rigoureusement les mêmes
En utilisant les équations de la mécanique des fluides de Navier-Stokes
on peut montrer mathématiquement que la force de portance calculée par le principe de Bernoulli
est exactement égale à celle de la troisième loi de Newton
Et quelque part, d'un point de vue physique c'est pas du tout surprenant, hein
mais bon visiblement beaucoup ne l'ont pas vu, et continuent de défendre avec ferveur l'une plutôt que l'autre
Alors pour ma part, sur le plan pédagogique, je trouve quand même l'explication à la Newton pas très éclairante
Oui, du fait de l'action-réaction, l'air est forcément dévié vers le bas
Mais contrairement au principe de Bernoulli, ça nous dit absolument rien de la nature des forces qui expliquent la portance
juste qu'il y en a forcément une
Mais bon retenez que ce débat Newton versus Bernoulli est un faux débat :
les deux explications sont parfaitement correctes, et quantitativement complètement équivalentes
Bien, alors faisons un petit bilan de ce que nous avons appris
Au niveau fondamental, on comprend très bien d'où vient la portance
on a des phénomènes de surpression-dépression
qui sont reliés à la vitesse de l'écoulement d'air autour de l'aile, ça c'est Bernoulli
et qui se traduisent au niveau microscopique par un différentiel de choc des molécules de l'air sur les faces des ailes
et qu'on voit de plus loin par le fait que l'écoulement d'air est globalement dévié vers le bas, ça c'est Newton
Ces théories, elles expliquent vraiment le phénomène de portance, mais pour calculer cette portance
elles partent du principe qu'on connaît la manière exacte dont l'air s'écoule autour de l'aile
sa vitesse en tout point, ce qu'on appelle le champ des vitesses
Une question qu'on peut se poser maintenant c'est : qu'est ce qui détermine ce champ des vitesses ?
Comme je vous l'ai dit la manière dont un fluide comme l'air s'écoule
est réglée par des équations qui sont connues, les équations de Navier-Stokes
et qui permettent en principe de calculer le champ des vitesses
quand on connaît la forme et la taille de l'aile, l'angle d'attaque et la vitesse de déplacement
En pratique ce qu'on aimerait savoir, c'est comment avoir une bonne portance, aussi élevé que possible
Il y a par exemple une chose qui ne se calcule pas très bien avec les équations mais qui est bien connue d'expérience
c'est qu'on ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi avec l'angle d'attaque :
au delà d'un certain angle, en général autour de 15 degrés, l'air se met à tourbillonner au dessus de la face supérieure
et cela perturbe complètement les flux, et provoque une perte importante de portance
c'est ce qu'on appelle le décrochage, qui est bien connu des pilotes d'avion
Au-delà de ce phénomène, quand des ingénieurs conçoivent des ailes pour un avion ou un planeur
ce qu'ils cherchent à faire c'est trouver une forme qui va permettre d'avoir le plus de portance possible
et le moins de traînée également
la difficulté c'est que, en pratique, résoudre les équations de Navier-Stokes et trouver la forme exacte de l'écoulement d'air
même avec un gros ordinateur c'est presque impossible car les calculs sont très très lourds
et de fait on peut se demander s'il existe des principes
qui permettent de comprendre l'impact des différentes formes d'aile sans avoir à faire tout ça
Et bien il y en a un qui semble séduisant et qui est fréquemment mentionné
c'est celui dit "du temps de transit égal"
Ce principe nous dit que si l'air va plus vite sur le dessus d'une aile que sur le dessous
et bien c'est tout simplement parce que du fait de la forme de l'aile
la trajectoire à parcourir est plus grande au dessus qu'en dessous
et donc l'air doit aller plus vite au dessus pour compenser, pour que les deux flux d'air se rejoignent en sortie
On dit que leur temps de transit sera égal
Le problème de cette explication, c'est qu'elle est complètement fausse
D'une part, on arrive très bien à faire voler des avions avec des ailes à profil symétrique
où la distance à parcourir est la même sur les deux faces
un cas extrême d'ailleurs étant l'avion en papier qui a des ailes plates
Et en plus quand on compare les temps de parcours de l'air qui passe au-dessus et en dessous
soit par une simulation soit par une expérience
eh bien ça n'est pas vrai que les flux se rejoignent
En fait le flux d'air supérieur est de toute façon beaucoup plus rapide que ça
on le voit en soufflerie si on lâche de la fumée par courtes impulsions, comme sur cette vidéo
ça permet de suivre les paquets de fumée et de voir que ceux qui passent au-dessus
arrivent en sortie bien en avance par rapport à ceux qui passent en dessous
Et pareil sur ma simulation : si on lâche plein de poussières simultanément en amont dans le flux
eh bien les poussières qui passent par le dessus atteignent l'arrière de l'aile bien plus rapidement que les autres
Donc ce principe du temps de transit égal entre les deux faces de l'aile est faux
Et en fait, de façon assez étonnante
c'est à cause de ça que certaines personnes mal informées en sont venus à rejeter aussi le principe de Bernoulli
Il faut dire que les deux explications ont été souvent présentées ensemble :
on lit parfois "l'air doit aller plus vite au-dessus à cause du chemin plus long
et Bernoulli fait que cette vitesse plus élevée engendre une dépression, et donc de la portance"
Mais il faut bien voir que ce sont deux choses différentes :
Bernoulli nous explique l'origine de la portance quand on a un certain écoulement d'air
la théorie du temps de transit égal, elle, prétend expliquer les caractéristiques de l'écoulement à partir de celles de l'aile
et cette partie est fausse
mais ça ne remet pas du tout en question le principe de Bernoulli
Ok bon, mais si cette approche est fausse
comment on fait pour concevoir simplement des ailes d'avion qui marchent bien ?
Et bien au tout début du 20e siècle, une très jolie solution a été proposée par deux chercheurs
un Allemand, Martin Kutta
et un russe, Nikolaï Joukowski
Alors comme vous vous en doutez, à cette époque il y avait pas d'ordinateurs
et donc résoudre les équations de Navier-Stokes pour calculer la portance c'était totalement exclu
et du coup ils ont fait un truc assez remarquable : ils ont simplifié à mort le problème
Alors pour ça ils ont fait un certain nombre d'hypothèses
dont on sait qu'elles sont toutes fausses dans le cas qui nous préoccupe
mais ils ont obtenu en contrepartie une forme très simplifiée des équations de Navier-Stokes
qu'ils ont pu résoudre à la main pour toute une famille de profils d'aile
Ça leur a permis de prédire la forme des écoulements d'air autour de ces ailes
et donc de calculer la portance, avec le principe de Bernoulli évidemment
Un des points remarquables de leur approche concerne une hypothèse en particulier :
le fait de supposer que l'air n'a pas de viscosité
alors d'une part déjà c'est faux, l'air a une certaine viscosité
mais en plus de ça, on sait que cette viscosité est indispensable pour expliquer les profils d'écoulement qu'on observe
en gros on peut démontrer que s'il n'y avait pas de viscosité
on n'aurait que des écoulements qui ne créent ni trainée ni portance
ça s'appelle le paradoxe de d'Alembert
Sauf que le truc qui les arrangeaient, c'est que cette viscosité elle n'agit en fait de façon significative
que vraiment tout près du profil de l'aile : dès qu'on s'éloigne un peu, on peut la négliger
et ce qu'on fait dans l'approche de Kutta-Joukowski, c'est qu'on néglige carrément la viscosité partout
mais on la prend en compte via un critère de sélection des solutions des équations
Ce critère permet de ramener le rôle total de la viscosité à un seul paramètre, qu'on appelle la circulation
et qui est en gros la quantification du tourbillon qui se forme autour de l'aile du fait des variations de vitesse
pour visualiser ça, si par exemple je représente les vitesses de l'air par des petites flèches
et que je me place cette fois dans le référentiel de l'air, où il est immobile au loin
eh bien vous voyez que l'air sous l'aile est poussé vers l'avant, et que l'air au-dessus de l'aile est attiré à l'arrière
ce qui crée un tourbillon global
c'est ça qu'on appelle la circulation, dont l'intensité peut être directement reliée à la portance
Alors je vous passe les détails techniques, mais ce que je veux que vous reteniez
c'est que Kutta-Joukowski ça n'est pas une autre théorie de la portance
qui viendrait concurrencer ou remplacer ce qu'on a vu avant
c'est plutôt un cadre d'analyse à la main sans ordinateur
pour essayer de prédire la forme du champ des vitesses de l'écoulement
pour certains types d'aile, et notamment ceux ayant ce qu'on appelle un "bord de fuite tranchant", comme ceci
Donc dans mon schéma, Kutta-Jukowski se place ici
ça permet de calculer des écoulements, et ensuite on utilise comme toujours Bernoulli pour calculer la portance
Ce qui est intéressant avec cette approche, c'est déjà que historiquement elle a été très féconde pour étudier des écoulements
mais en plus, mathématiquement elle est vraiment très belle
si vous aimez les équations différentielles et l'analyse complexe je vous conseille d'aller jeter un oeil
Évidemment, ces travaux-là sont anciens : ils datent de 1902 et 1905
c'était exactement l'époque des premier vol des frères Wright
et bien sûr les choses ont pas mal évolué depuis
et notamment, maintenant on sait mieux résoudre les équations de Navier-Stokes, avec des ordinateurs
en se passant de certaines des hypothèses qui avaient été faites par Kutta et Joukowski
et ça permet de préciser un certain nombre de phénomènes nouveaux
Par exemple quand on regarde les profils d'aile en 3D et plus seulement 2D
on sait que la différence de pression entre le dessus et le dessous de l'aile
entraîne un flux tourbillonnant aux extrémités, qu'on essaye d'ailleurs de contrôler
avec l'aide de ces petites ailettes verticales qu'on retrouve sur certaines ailes
On est capable aussi d'étudier un certain nombre de phénomènes d'instabilité
et de trouver des astuces pour essayer de retarder le phénomène de décrochage des avions quand l'angle d'attaque augmente
Alors malgré tout, certains d'entre vous ont peut-être entendu qu'il y a quelques années, en 2016
un groupe de physiciens danois a proposé une soi-disant "nouvelle théorie"
censée mettre au placard tout ce qui avait été dit avant
et nous expliquant que tout était faux mais que eux avaient enfin tout compris
Alors j'étais déjà méfiant parce qu'ils ont fait un marketing d'enfer: des vidéos,  sites web, bouquins, etc
nous expliquant qu'ils avaient découvert, je cite, "le secret du vol"
mais en définitive l'article scientifique a semble-t-il eu un impact assez faible
il est d'ailleurs peu cité par les chercheurs du domaine
Alors je me suis un peu plongé dedans et sans être un spécialiste
j'ai l'impression que ce qu'ils racontent est certainement correct, mais ça n'est pas du tout une "nouvelle théorie"
En gros ils ont utilisé des grosse simulations des équations de Navier-Stokes
en 3d, instationnaire, tout ça, sur un superordinateur
et ils ont mis en évidence un certain nombre de choses
notamment des instabilités en arrière de l'aile, qui ont un rôle dans les détails du profil de vitesse
Alors très bien, mais d'une part ça ne remet absolument pas en question la portance selon Bernoulli ou Newton comme vous voulez
mais contrairement à ce qu'ils disent, ça ne montre pas du tout que Kutta-Joukowski est faux
ou que la circulation n'existe pas
Revenons à mon schéma pour bien comprendre
Cette approche supposément nouvelle se place au niveau de la prédiction du champ des vitesses
avec leur grosse simulation, les physiciens danois mettent en évidence des choses que par essence
on peut pas capturer avec les calculs de Kutta et Joukowski, très bien
Mais de là à appeler ça une nouvelle théorie
à dire que les autres ont tout faux et que eux ont découvert le secret du vol
il me semble qu'il y a une grosse survente des résultats
Mais bon, vous savez que ça existe aussi chez les scientifiques
Voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui, j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura donné une vision un peu plus claire de comment les avions volent
vous pouvez donc dormir tranquille lors de votre prochain décollage
Pour les plus curieux, j'ai écrit un billet de blog qui complète cette vidéo, qui donne quelques détails techniques
notamment sur la manière dont j'ai fait les simulations que je vous ai montrées, et je mettrai probablement le code en partage
Un merci particulier aux professeurs Babinsky de Cambridge, qui m'a autorisé à montrer ses vidéos de visualisation des flux d'air en soufflerie
Comme toujours, abonnez-vous, la cloche, tout ça
les actus de la chaîne c'est facebook et twitter, et on se retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo